staying with congress now negotiators on
capitol hill are trying to complete work
on a new coronavirus relief bill by
midnight tonight
and lawmakers are working on a more than
900 billion dollar package of benefits
for millions of americans
they want to attach that package to
another funding bill that would prevent
a government shutdown overnight
as nancy cordes reports the delay has
real implications for millions of
americans
we're staying right here until covert
relief
is out the door as negotiations over a
stimulus bill
drag on food banks just miles from the
capitol are being
inundated radha muthaya of capital area
food bank says the number of
local people in need has grown by 50
percent
they used to be our volunteers they used
to be our donors
they never anticipated being on the
other side of the line so to speak and
asking for food should have been done
months ago house majority leader steny
hoyer
argues that even belated aid will help
families
especially that new round of stimulus
checks how big are they going to be
and who's going to get them we're now
talking about 700
dollars per family so that would be
fourteen hundred dollars for a husband
and wife or
partners the bill also contains three
hundred dollars a week in federal
unemployment benefits
and three hundred billion dollars for
small businesses
but the restaurants act may get left out
that's a proposed 120 billion dollar
fund
aimed at helping small restaurant owners
like amanda cohen
who runs a vegetarian joint in new york
city it feels
a lot like we have been abandoned more
than 110
000 restaurants have already closed for
good this year
without help cohen worries hers will be
next
there comes a point when you run a
business where you just can't keep
throwing
money down the toilet you know we are
hemorrhaging it right now
congressional leaders continue to insist
they are almost done
with the deal but if the house and
senate do not vote today we
are looking at the possibility of a
short-term
government shutdown over the weekend the
good news tony
is that once the bill does pass the
first stimulus checks
can start going out within a couple of
weeks all right sooner than i expected
nancy thank you very much